oh dude i gotta ask you some
questions about content is that okay
oh man because don't make it so exciting
i know well i just hate every time we go
on a podcast and people are like so fine
but i'm like just genuinely curious
about like how you do it you put out
more good [ __ ] than anybody like the
frequency the amount and the quality is
all so good like how what's your how do
you do it what's your process uh i don't
know man i just love making things and i
just always find time for it so like in
the morning i'll just hop on twitter
either ruin my day or find something
interesting going on if it's something i
have like a strong opinion about or if
it's goofy enough i'll usually just make
something joking about it and then like
when it comes to
you know movies or game reviews or
something like i just recently watched
dragon ball evolution and made like a
[ __ ] video essay on how bad that is i
just love watching bad movies and stuff
or any entertainment medium bad music
bad game bad show bad movie so i'll just
watch them for fun and then if i have
like anything interesting to say about
it or if i think people would find it
interesting i'll make something on it
and then i'll usually work out sometime
in the afternoon and then come back and
look for more goofy [ __ ] going on in the
world
find anything just degenerate for like
horrific information just like what i
can't get away
i just [ __ ] love it man there's just
there's so much wacky stuff out there
that a lot of people would never even
find if they don't like
aggressively look like i do like
obsessed with it this is fun i don't
know i just find it all so fascinating
yeah i mean i went on like a 10 minute
spiral last night on did you ever watch
like the crypto bizinacci
animations
the dude like um oh this is crazy i got
one i got something that you haven't
seen before
seriously oh yeah i'm only bringing this
up because i relate to you on like
obsessing over something so this this
dude like he made these like hilarious
crypto animations and like just making
fun of like what it's like to own crypto
and he hasn't uploaded anything in four
years now you know because of the crypto
crash i'm like where the [ __ ] is this
dude like this would be the time and
then i just found myself deep on like
archived like 4chan threads
you know discussing this dude
and it like netted out in like no
results it was just like yeah this dude
killed himself i'm pretty sure oh
yeah yikes but then it was like
unsubstantiated i only bring that up to
say like do you do you ever experience
that where you try to go deep on
something and then you just get to a
conclusion that's just sort of like damn
that this is just sad like i can't
really do anything with this oh that
happens all the time some of my favorite
rabbit holes end in like tragedy and i'm
like damn this conclusion maybe like i
can do something if i don't say what
happened then i'm like nah i know what
happened now it's not as fun yeah yeah
a lot of like the really like fun goofy
stories that you'll read on the internet
like always have like a not great
conclusion yeah
yeah just always end in suicide yeah
it's just something like tragic you
remember that guy who collected jelly
beans yeah he murdered his family
oh sick the senator actually ended up
killing himself
what are your what are your other like
pressing interview questions cody i'm
curious i'm just i'm like i've always
like watched your stuff and i've been
thought how does he [ __ ] do it for me
to
make a like a narrative video where i'm
breaking something down like 75 of the
time i have to write it i have to spend
like three four hours like writing it
making sure there's jokes in it and
you're doing one of those like every
single day on top of three other videos
on top of streaming for four hours on
top of music on top of whatever else you
do it's like how do you do it
you make me sound like a lot more
impressive than i am i i just i just
shoot the [ __ ] so i don't write anything
and i think that's why i always have
more time to make things because
i've never liked writing jokes i've
never i've also never been good at like
writing jokes either so usually i'll
just like start talking and go off the
top and see what happens and the content
you guys produce is a lot more high
effort and a lot more like buttoned up
than mine is my content you know
maybe 30 minutes to talk about you know
radio shack doing some dumb [ __ ] on
twitter and all of that was just like on
twitch you know like a 30-minute
40-minute segway and it's like that was
fun that might be a fun topic people
might want to hear about so then i'll
post it the longer content i'll do like
dragon ball evolution breaking it down
it's me watching the video and then i'll
just
well watch it again and then make jokes
about it i just find there's a lot more
hours in the day than a lot of people
realize it's just a matter of like how
it gets spent and like broken up
and then you have yeah do you have a
team that helps you or like people that
like up your twitch streams and post
them and all that stuff yeah so
buddymind chase edits the twitch streams
at least most of them sometimes i'll
still do it if i'm not doing anything
else i'll just edit some some that i
thought were fun but for all the videos
where it's like
me talking at the webcam or you know
like uh any kind of product review or
something like that it's just me irl
stuff it's me and my team which is about
seven people now and we just do whatever
we think is fun then they'll throw like
a good edit together so anything where
it's more than just splicing like audio
together is done by someone else but
everything else is made
and i can't
yeah so like at home here i'm just done
like a logitech webcam and then irl
stuff is on like a sony uh that's what i
appreciate most about what you do man is
how like it's just very regular gear i
think that's so sick
because everyone now is like it's like a
[ __ ] arms race with cameras and yeah
in tech and lighting and all that [ __ ]
and i just think it's dope that you just
sit down and you just hit record and
you're like
yes i found this guy who likes to lick
shoes
[Laughter]
no it is it is sick it's like inspiring
honestly yeah i appreciate that i i do
think and i don't want anyone to think
that i i look down on anyone that uses
good gear or nothing i think it is like
extremely important to have a good setup
like the only reason i don't is just
because i i wouldn't know how to use it
even if i set it up i'm kind of like a
neanderthal when it comes to technology
anyway so like a webcam works fine for
me like i actually only recently
upgraded to a webcam for the first like
four years i just set my phone up on my
trumpet case and just had it that is
crazy yeah
i treat youtube just kind of like a
diary of things i find interesting and
yeah just lucky enough that other people
find them interesting too yeah that's
what i was going to ask you about next
is like i mean for the la for like my
whole time on youtube i've i pretend
like i don't but i kind of obsessed over
like numbers and
what's getting likes and yeah like
making sure everything's super buttoned
up and
feels like cohesive and stuff and the
fact that you just like cut up your
twitch streams and just add like put
them all on youtube were you ever
concerned about quantity and how that
would affect the algorithm and do you
even think about that at all or you're
just like i'm just i just i like this
i'm putting it out yeah so i've always
come into the mindset of where like
youtube's never been a job for me like
obviously like now i live off of content
creation but i've never treated it like
a job so it's always just been
i had fun with this i'll post it i had
fun learning about this i'll make
something about this and it's just not
something that really crosses my mind
sometimes with a title i'll try and
think of like a really goofy title that
people might be like interested to click
on outside of like the normal audience
but yeah usually it's just
this was fun so i think other people
might have fun with it too or at least i
hope they do yeah i think i think that
attitude honestly comes through man i i
think that's why
you're just the stuff you make this does
so well because yeah honestly i think
that's why you know it doesn't even
matter what you're shooting it on
because it's so apparent that you just
enjoy it i i think that's something that
it's so easy to lose when you make stuff
for work like like content because
that's the number one thing that people
gravitate towards is like they can tell
if you like what you're doing and like
if you don't like they can sniff that
out and i think that turns people off to
what you're doing you know or if you are
doing it solely to make money or
whatever like that's a bit more obvious
but i mean like cody said it's inspiring
man i like i just love watching your
[ __ ] like it just feels very genuine i
feel like you're one of the
like most authentic people on the
internet honestly
i really appreciate all the kind words
jesus yeah you had me on the podcast
just to be nice yeah you're just gonna
talk about weiners and stuff
thank you guys
you